tonight new developments in the showdown
over a classified memo on alleged
surveillance abuses by the FBI in the
Russia investigation President Trump is
expected to approve the release of the
documents after agreeing to some
redactions at the FBI's request it could
be declassified possibly by tomorrow
morning this afternoon Speaker Paul Ryan
advocated for its release as long as
sources and methods are revealed let me
tell you what this memo is and what this
memory is not what this memo is is
Congress doing its job in conducting
legitimate oversight over a very unique
law FISA and if mistakes were made and
if individuals did something wrong then
it is our job as the legislative branch
of government to conduct oversight over
the executive branch if abuses were made
what this is not is an indictment on our
institutions of our justice system this
memo is not indictment of the FBI
of the Department of Justice it does not
impugn the Moller investigation or the
Deputy Attorney General the government
has been given extraordinary power over
citizens civil liberties it is our job
to make sure that the process is
followed properly the memo was
commissioned by Devin Nunez the
Republican chairman of the House
Intelligence panel Democratic leaders
Pelosi and Schumer have called for Nunez
removal as chair accusing him of waging
a cover-up campaign for the White House
but Speaker Ryan says he will not be
doing so they're just playing politics
and I think they're looking for a
political distraction is what I get out
of that Devin nudists helped Shepherd
through a reauthorization of 702 which
is the foreign terrorist foreign
surveillance law so he's focusing on
keeping our country safe focus on
national security I think what they're
trying to do is just sidetrack us with
some political game okay Dana so we're
probably it sounds like gonna get some
big breaking news on this tomorrow if
it's gonna release in terms of the
reporting if that meets with the
expectation is what do you think that we
can expect and what do you think about
this messaging I'm not sure I understand
what speaker Ryan is trying to do a
couple of things one is trying to
explain that the there that the memo has
nothing to do with the
Moeller investigation I really think
that's a very tough communications bar
to clear because even if that were even
if it's true that it has nothing to do
with it everybody assumes it has
something to do with it and all these
background sources say that the the
White House or something the White House
sometimes they say the President
believes that this is actually going to
help him in the court of public opinion
thinking that there is bias against him
and therefore it questions the
credibility of the whole Russia
investigation then you have the FISA
issue which is there's lots of different
titles in the FISA bill we talked about
this the other day that where you have
foreign terrorists calling in to
Americans and there you get a warrant
warrantless wiretap that's one part of
the FISA program what I understand is
that the concerns about possible abuses
or inappropriateness it's in a different
title in title one which is about
basically going after a warrant for an
American here so that's where the abuse
is apparently were and maybe they'll be
able to clarify this when it goes
forward just before we came to air Axios
is reporting on backgrounds from
background sources that some people in
the White House are fearful that maybe
this isn't all it's cracked up to be
and that maybe it's been overhyped and
when speaker Ryan says that Pelosi and
Schumer are just calling for a
distraction by saying that Nunez should
step down as the chairman of the
Intelligence Committee you do have to
think that the Republicans have actually
been looking for a distraction for the
past couple of weeks as they've gone
through the proper channels to try to
figure out a way to release the memo
mm-hmm okay
all right Jesse what do you make of the
little bit of perhaps are they / hyping
this or what do you think what we expect
I fear there could be some overhyping
and I'm nervous about it because they've
been hyping this thing bigger than I've
ever seen and if they don't deliver
everyone's going to be very disappointed
with that said the way Pelosi is acting
and the way Eric Holder is acting or
they James Comey is acting it leads me
to believe that the Democrats at least
think that it's a very damning memo and
it is going to hurt the Democrats and
it's going to raise a lot of questions
about the Russia investigation and
that's exactly what Paul Ryan says that
it's not right so is why I think the
community Republicans communication
jeana's hard because they're saying this
has nothing to do with the russia
investigation and bob molar but it is
being conflated right a reason a
reasonably so and I think the conflation
comes in terms of one of the things I
think the reporting says that we do know
is that this dossier that was paid for
by Hillary and was fake was used as the
justification to spy on the Trump
campaign that seems like the hardest bit
of evidence we have as far as anything
else
it looks like commis been implicated in
some capacity Rosenstein has been
implicated I've heard those names been
bandied about now they want to redact
those names I don't see what redacting
names will do they're now saying that
they've changed the memo that's a lie I
think there was a grammatical change and
then the other change was something that
the Democrats wanted so the smokescreen
that the Democrats like to say is this
is a smokescreen for the Russia
investigation the Democrats are now
deploying a smokescreen for the abuse of
power because right now it does look
like when people were debating this for
many years
no we're worried about the Fourth
Amendment we're worried about the
federal government knowing too much and
abusing their power and getting into
personal stuff it looks like some of
those fears were founded on on you know
actual reality so we'll see what happens
I'm sick of hearing about it just
release the damn thing okay so tomorrow
Jesse they can be they'll be over for
you Greg so what do you make of this in
terms of you know Paul Ryan coming out
making this statement the White House a
lot of new some people wanted this to
come out today ahead of time versus
Friday yeah I I have this sense I love
our viewers I love our viewers so much
that I have sometimes you have to give
them some tough talk this is a memo
intervention the more this is played up
on cable news the less it may be you've
seen this happen with other scandals
it's I call it letdown itis you get
built up and it creates a lot of ratings
and a lot of fire and a lot of fury and
then it just fizzles and then we move on
to something else it's like the reboot
of full house I was looking forward for
to that for ages and then when he came
out it was just a big letdown it's a and
what your
with the Russian collusion thing it's
the same thing with which you know the
facts there are thinner than Stelter
Zaire you look at that and then you look
you look at that and then you look at
the memo it's like competitive
striptease one side is saying look at
this look at this and then the other
side is look at this look at this and
then when you look at that and you look
at that you realize this is the worst
strip club ever I mean if you look at
MSNBC Rachel is fantastic and every day
she's selling that story she's selling
that story and then if you come to other
networks
it's the memo other networks and isn't
selling that story so it's scandal
ping-pong and it's near you but it's
really just scandal ping-pong sex
scandal pong and I just what I'm saying
is I could be completely wrong I've been
wrong before I hate talking about stuff
that I don't know about but if I follow
that I would never open my mouth so I am
gonna say a prediction that we probably
will be let down and and if I'm wrong
then we'll talk about it tomorrow
probably leave with it what a happy
Friday it will be okay so one I'm do you
think here in terms of with the
Republicans some of the messaging that
they've gotten ahead of the game here or
how do you see this well I think that
the the purpose is pretty apparent which
is that President Trump doesn't like the
investigation he's trying to undermine
the FBI Justice Department as part of an
effort to get his supporters to
disbelieve anything that comes from the
special councilor any of these
investigatory agencies what's striking
to me about this is you had the director
of the FBI Christopher Rae go over to
the White House to meet with the White
House chief of staff John Kelly
accompanied by rod Rosen Stein who's the
Deputy Attorney General and both said
this would be a reckless act it would
endanger national security to have this
put out there that this was a
cherry-pick document there are missions
of facts they are things that are
distorted in here and it will lead to
you know methods and and sources being
divulged and they asked now these are
two Trump appointees this is not the
Democrats which I guess we can easily
you know just picking up on what Greg
was them and get into team sport
politics here but it's some
you have to look out for American
institutions and trust in law
enforcement and here despite what Paul
Ryan says we have the president putting
his interest his disinclination to
listen and abide by anything that's
coming from the Muller investigation
over the best interest of American
people and I'm surprised for Republicans
over the best interests of law
enforcement in the United States so
that's funny because you because for the
so long we've been told how heroic
whistleblowers are for exposing all this
information I mean where's the Chelsea
Manning fan club right now why aren't
they saying release the memo that I I
really don't think there's any reason
for secrecy in this memo because I do
think what's in the memo we already know
but I think that the idea that it's
top-secret
is unfair to the American people well
here's the thing that they the same
group that says let's be transparent
says no Democrats your memo can't go out
that's not true and then secondly when
they asked about the classified
information behind the document that if
you believe in transparency no no we
can't put that out so you just have to
listen to our interpretation I don't
think the president's trying to
undermine anything I think Congress is
doing oversight and that's what the job
of Congress is you also said that the
FBI doesn't want it out of course they
don't want it out because it's very
embarrassing to the FBI and all of a
sudden Juan Williams trusts law
enforcement I just want the record to
show that for the last year you've said
the law enforcement needs to be have
body cameras on them and you know we
have to look out for bias and law
enforcement now we actually have
evidence of bias in law enforcement and
you don't want to know about it Juan
when is the media not wanted more
information Jesse I always thought you
as a journalist would want more yes I
know it's I don't know you're on such
weak ground I understand why you want to
do some kind of personal attack on me
but let me just say if I talk about your
words you get about police in the
streets and black communities I'm not
talking about the FBI looking at our
politicians if there's a bias it's a
positive patrolling a black neighborhood
that doesn't like black people you
suspect are you that black up so if
there's a bias FBI agent that doesn't
like Donald Trump and he's overseeing
the investigation smokes wouldn't you
crush it
I tell you what maybe then you should
walk back and look at the newspaper
that's a great for us the point I am
because yesterday the age and who you
say doesn't like Donald Trump it was
disclosed was the guy who wrote the memo
saying let's go after Hillary Clinton
let's reopen this thing ten days before
the election and you know what else
happened McCabe who was just let go to
go collect his pension knew about these
extra emails that Hillary had with Huma
and weiner and didn't tell James Comey
for weeks for weeks let me tell you why
not want what what was he hiding we
wasn't hiding anything he why did he
wait wait to tell James Comey no these
extra II because ultimately and by the
way call me has said this nothing has
come out that would justify having
prosecuted Hillary what about this the
great thing about this is we are all
arguing about something that nobody's
read outside of a few people all right
we will know we will know too much it's
tomorrow
Dana I can't wait my alarm I would say
there's one other point yeah The Wall
Street Journal just posted a news
article about Carter page and the
original FISA warrant which it says was
not during the Trump campaign it goes
back to 2013 right and there's
additional information in this article
that I think what you'll see is I don't
know how the Wall Street Journal got it
but if this memo comes out tomorrow and
the Democrats want their memo released
as well you can bet that there will
probably be other information that
somehow leaks out and tries to at least
get to the bottom of it maybe we will
all we'll know more tomorrow after these
article that just posted around four
o'clock is important let me ask you
something before we go what happens for
you any of you if in fact the president
says Rob Rosen sign you know you're
implicated in its number I want you gone
and I'm gonna put somebody in there who
I think can rein in this Muller
investigation would you say boy this is
horrible I can't believe that the
president would interfere with the law
enforcement agencies of this country in
this manner to protect themselves you're
posing a question about something that
hasn't happened yet or you don't think
it's a setup for firing roses I'm just
askin that's what okay right well and
the president didn't author the memo